le plan de relance at il laissé la gent
féminine de côté c'est en tout cas ce
que révèle une étude de la fondation des
femmes paru le 29 mars
bien que touché de plein fouet par la
crise sanitaire les femmes ne sont pas
soutenues par le plan de relance
économique de 100 milliards d'euros
france vole ans ainsi selon l'organisme
nous sommes face à un risque de
régression inédite de l'égalité femmes
hommes
l'étude restitue le contexte dans lequel
se trouvent les femmes depuis le début
de l'épidémie
le confinement de mars 2020 les a
particulièrement affecté se sont
davantage sacrifier pour la carrière de
leurs partenaires elles sont ainsi 40 %
à avoir consacré plus de quatre heures
par jour aux enfants soit le double des
hommes elles sont 21% à s'être arrêté de
travailler à cette occasion soit encore
une fois le double des hommes
le tout alors que les postes de première
ligne était particulièrement occupés par
des femmes
citons les infirmières les caissières
les agents d'entretien et j'en passe des
postes qui pour la plupart n'ont pas
fait l'objet de revalorisation salariale
des emplois souvent précaires soient les
premiers à être détruits en temps de
crise mais malheureusement personne n'a
été à leur chevet pour anticiper leurs
soucis d'emploi pendant et après la
crise du coc vide ainsi que pour
intégrer leurs spécificités à ce
programme de relance
ce plan de 100 milliards annoncés en
septembre 2020 pour assurer le retour de
la croissance
les a tout bonnement oublié malgré des
demandes des organismes concernés des
pouvoirs publics ont refusé de mettre en
place une analyse de genre et un suivi
des politiques budgétaires et de leur
impact sur les femmes
ça commence en fanfare mais voyons en
quoi consiste ce plan aveugle au genre
ce sont les investissements massifs en
faveur de la transition écologique et de
la souveraineté et de la compétitivité
économique de la france les hommes sont
sur représentés dans des secteurs les
plus aidés qui constitue d'ailleurs une
faible part du marché de l'emploi 8
milliards d'euros pour l'automobile 15
milliards pour l'aéronautique 4
milliards pour les entreprises
technologiques et 8 milliards pour le
secteur du bâtiment et des travaux
publics
sur les 35 milliards du plan de relance
seulement 7 milliards sont dédiés à des
emplois considérés comme féminins mais
pourtant ces secteurs ne leur sont pas
fermées il faudrait juste les soutenir
par exemple
nières années celui des hautes
technologies a perdu 11% de ses emplois
féminins
seuls 16% de femmes sont employées dans
le secteur de la transition écologique
il n'existe pas dans le rapport de
politique volontariste de féminisation
de ces emplois là rayon disques
alisation est une priorité mais l'emploi
des femmes dans l'industrie dans n'est
apparemment pas une
certes récemment le ségur de la santé a
permis de revaloriser les salaires de
nombreuses professionnels du domaine
sanitaire
mais ces augmentations n'ont pas pris en
compte les écarts de rémunération pré
existant entre les femmes et les hommes
dommage et puis il n'existe toujours
rien pour conditionner l'attribution des
fonds publics aux entreprises respectant
des règles de parité ou engageant des
actions en faveur de l'égalité hommes
femmes
la fondation des femmes proposons de
faire reculer ces inégalités
en examinant la manière dont l'accès des
femmes à l'emploi est obstruée et en
considérant aussi des données telles que
la fragilité des métiers de première
ligne ou encore les répercussions des
violences conjugales
il faudra revoir la réforme de
l'assurance-chômage adapter les
conditions du télétravail et ses
transformations suppose que toutes les
aides du plan de relance soit
conditionnée au respect de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes
il ya donc du pain sur la planche à voir
au prochain quinquennat